president trump is back on the campaign
trail attacking his opponents and
causing controversy during his rally in
tulsa
i've been watching the fake news for
weeks now and everything is negative
don't go don't come don't do anything
today it was like
i've never seen anything like it i've
never seen anything like it
you are warriors thank you joe biden is
not the leader of his party
joe biden is a helpless puppet of the
radical left
here's the bad part when you testif when
you do testing to that extent
you're going to find more people you're
going to find more cases
so i said to my people slow the testing
down please
meanwhile president trump is facing a
new wave of criticism over a smaller
than expected crowd size
even after the media was critical of the
president for holding a rally during the
pandemic
in the first place uh katie i think one
of the things that was happening with
the over
promising under delivering on the crowd
size is that
the trump campaign and supporters
they're looking for a metric
to show that they are better than joe
biden so
the fundraising and the abiding campaign
did a little bit better the poll numbers
that did a little bit better
but we know that the enthusiasm gap
between trump and biden
is quite large meaning people that want
to vote for president trump are
very enthusiastic about doing so um
the president will be going to arizona
later this week i know that's your home
town home to home state i should say so
what what do they learn from the tulsa
experience to take with them as they
continue out on the campaign trail
well i would say the first thing is to
verify the numbers of ticket sales
versus
uh who is going to show up but look this
this comparison between
the joe biden campaign in the trump
campaign and the riff on the trump
campaign that somehow it's a failure
because
quote only 6 000 people showed up to the
first
rally in months during the end of a
pandemic
and in the aftermath of these riots and
protests i think is a pretty silly
argument to make especially considering
joe biden had a town hall last week
where people were hand-picked there were
20 people there
and there wasn't any enthusiasm and so
moving forward
um i'm sure as you noted in the
communications
sphere they will not be over promising
who is
exactly going to show up because you
just don't know who's going to show up
but the historic the history of these
rallies is that there are
massive overflow crowds i know people
who have waited in line for hours to get
in
and never did in places like arizona so
um i think that they'll be just fine
when it comes to getting these rallies
back on the road
and the president you know they say that
most of the majority of life is showing
up
well trump is showing up and biden is
not
and juan the trump campaign the trump
white house explained today that the
president
was clearly joking when he said that he
encouraged the administration to slow
down testing
to make the numbers look better the
white house reiterated that today
the biden campaign though they decided
to take the ball and run with it
and they're going to try to use this
even though the president says he was
joking what do you think about that
let's just take the president's word
dana it's if he thinks that's funny i
don't i didn't find it funny i don't
think many people found it funny because
the virus is pretty serious and even in
places
like oklahoma and arizona where he's
going next we've seen the spike in the
continuation of the
problem so to me look i i
i think this was an epic embarrassment
for president trump who has made a
big big deal out of crowd sizes and the
idea that his own campaign said it was
going to be
a million plus and built a stage
outdoors to have a second speech for the
overflow
all of that came to not it just didn't
happen
so i mean you know at some point you
have to take some responsibility that's
not the media that's not the democrats
that's the trump campaign
and the other point i think that you
have to say here is that the polls were
right
if you know picking up on what katie was
saying if people were worried about
the virus it's not just democrats or the
media or
i don't know who but in in a deep red
state like oklahoma maybe people are
worried about the virus
and maybe that's one of the reasons
people didn't come out in the numbers
that had
been forecast but overall i'd say
on the merits of it and this gets to
what you were talking about
when i heard what the president was
saying it just struck me that gosh
this is like a summer rerun i've seen
this tv show before
there's not anything new here the whole
division i mean he's not running against
hillary clinton
he's running against joe biden to say
joe biden is a captive of the radical
left
is kind of wild everybody knows joe
biden's centrist
he's moderate so laughs a little bit
i want to play this i want to play this
sound um for you dan bongino
of the president you're trying to have a
little bit of a lighter moment with
something
that had happened the weekend before
take a look
i said general i've got myself a problem
general
because i'm wearing leather bottom shoes
it had no handrail
it was like an ice skating rink i've
taken water
and it spills down under your tie it
doesn't look good for a long time
and frankly the tie is never the same so
i put it up to my lip and then i say
because i don't want it just in case
and they gave me another disease
dan there is something about somebody a
politician no matter who it is if they
can
have a lighter moment and make you laugh
you can hit a home run
yeah it's a skill and not many
politicians are good at that because
their laughs are dictated then by focus
group
tested talking points focus groups tell
them the stories that's funny
tell that story people it's so weird he
just tells these stories they're in his
head
and as a guy who's worn leather sold
shoes in the secret service for 12 years
on marble flaws
floors it's like an ice skating rink so
i can't even imagine what a metal ramp
is like
but just one if i may if i may come back
at you for a minute an epic
embarrassment i mean come on
that's a little hyperbolic to say the
least so we're in the middle of
of this uh viral outbreak the media's
got everybody thinking if they're going
to show up they're going to die but if
you show up to a protest don't worry
you're a-okay the virus don't do
anything won't do anything to you
he still gets by secret service
estimates by the way between 10 and 12
000 people i'll trust them because they
do the flow rate at the magnetometer
there may not have been 10 or 12
000 inside but there were certainly 10
or 12 000 people that showed up and were
swept
12 000 people so by my estimates here if
joe biden had an
unbelievable 20 people at his rally
which katie referenced
which looked more like a pinocchio game
maybe parcheesi
that means president trump had 600 times
more people at his rally
than biden's so i ask you this if it's a
binary choice which it is juan
trump biden who do you want to be you
want to be the guy with 12 000 people or
you want to be playing parcheesi in your
living room
with your starbucks with 20 of your
neighbors i'll take the trump rally any
day of the week they have nothing to
apologize we don't have time for juan to
respond but
jesse you were there covering this live
for us
what do you know about the whole event
and going forward as the president
heads to arizona later this week
well i'll respond on juan's behalf and
i'll just say dan you're right i admit
that i was wrong
and campaign and crowd sizes are now a
barometer for enthusiasm
and uh and joe has no juice because
honestly
joe would kill for this small trump
crowd size
he'll never get 10 000 never has never
will
i think he cracked 1 000 once at his
main launch
event so please joe can't fill a library
let alone a stadium like that and the
media has been telling everybody hey
don't go to this event
it's dangerous and dangerous so the
trump supporters don't go
shouldn't they have been patting the
trump supporters on the back for being
smart and healthy no they're just trying
to embarrass the president
it's like jordan he scores 20 instead of
30.
okay you think he lost his game he'll
put up 20 open up 30 and 40 in the next
event
well joe can't even score once i mean
come on there's not even a comparison
here
meanwhile you're trying you're trying
baby
you're i don't need jesse jessie's on
the defensive
oh my gosh